hey leute herzlich willkommen zu einer
oben ein gotteskrieger im herzlich
willkommen zu einer minecraft 1.7 com
jahr explodiert herzlich willkommen zu
einer minecraft 1.7 update vorstellung
eigentlich wollte ich euch nur eine
sache vorstellen und dachte eigentlich
dass ich das gelesen habe dachte es
werden motto oder irgendwie sowas eine
modifikation es ist allerdings im update
dazu gekommen in der 1.7 punkt viel dir
jetzt vor ein paar tagen raus gekommen
ist und zwar wurde sehr wenig sachen
hinzugefügt es wird hinzugefügt dass es
schneller geht dass die welt ändert also
bei mojang arbeiten jetzt mehr leute die
sich halt mit den rändern sachen
auseinandersetzen
also die welt jetzt extrem schnell in
alle möglichen richtungen ich kann zum
beispiel jetzt dahin gucken da ist alles
schon geändert also jetzt nicht
irgendwie ich war noch nicht hinter
diesem berg aber ich sehe trotzdem was
da hinten schon ist so ihr seht schon
das generiert sich schon am horizont und
so das geht halt viel viel schneller
übrigens an alle die man vorher luca was
passiert da habt ihr den zieht wenn es
euch gefällt hier da vorne bin ich
angespannt
und was hat auch hinzugefügt wurde was
ich schon gesagt habe in den 26 mal das
schafft kurz daran hier ist ein tag den
ich auf job unterstrich habt das wird
halt dann zum regenbogen scharf also
wenn ich diese schafe habe es halt ein
regenbogen scharf das ist in allen
möglichen farben dann verfügbar wenn ihr
job unterstrich nennt m und was ist auch
noch dazu gekommen ist wenn ich mal ganz
kurz times etwas glaube ich times at
night machen und mal eben hier ganz
viele zombies tonne und zwar wurde ein
spezieller zombie zu gefühlt wenn ich
den gleich mal habt kann ich euch das
zeigen dass frauen vielleicht einmal bei
102 ps oder so deswegen musste ein
passwort
ich konnte es auch nicht vorbereiten
dann muss ich jetzt einfach so machen
damit ich euch das zeigen kann dass ich
dir noch hiermit aus dem krieg und den
ich irgendwie sport habt und zwar ist
das unserem special ding und zwar ein
kleiner zombie also so ein kleiner
zombie stelle ich wieder kostenbewussten
auf einem schicken ihr habe ich richtig
verstanden so ein kleiner zombie wird
auf einem gottverdammten kleinen bühne
schaukeln auf seinem kleinen schicken
sitzen und das ist ein rekord eilt also
der kommt sehr selten selten vor
wurde auch hinzugefügt ich dachte erst
als das gesehen habe so haye kann man
nämlich irgendwie nur durch irgendeinen
command bekommen den bekommt man nur
wenn man hier irgendwie so ganz viele
freunde nicht erst gar nicht bei mir
spontan team überhaupt gar keine
ich möchte euch doch einmal wenig
verzeichnet fall witzig
ja freuen ich habe jetzt die ganze zeit
so ein bisschen frauen und irgendwie
kommt hier grad gar keiner
also wenn ihr mal hier so guckt die
ganze insel ist voll mit diesen blöden
zombies ich habe keine ahnung warum
die sache ist jetzt allerdings die dass
ich euch jetzt einfach nicht belohnt
euch jetzt einfach mal ein bild davon
allen in dieser zombie aussieht dieser
größe zombie wenn ihr wisst wie man den
sport bei mir ist keiner gekommen wohin
ist bei mir angekommen als ich das
getestet habe weiß ich hab ich ja etwas
anderes gemacht habe aber hier im detail
kleiner gekommen weil er auch sehr sehr
selten vorkommt er ferrer welten und ich
hab ich jetzt einfach mal ein bild ein
gericht alles mögliche folge und mit
zombies gibt euch nur an dass ihn viele
da überhaupt befreit sind
es ist halt keiner gekommen ihr seht das
bild jetzt nicht mehr und die letzte
sache die hinzugefügt wurde die auch
mega geil es ist dass man jetzt direkt
über minecraft brotkasten kann also ich
muss dann meine county grady habe ich
aus wir sind drauf gedrückt jetzt bin
ich im browser geil
und dann kann ich hier über minecraft
direkt bei switch oder und 3d oder allen
möglichen anderen livestreaming
plattform direkt streamen und das ist
halt auch mega geil für die leute gerne
stream ich fühle mich super kerne wegen
beim schlechten internet aber na ja also
das geile an diesem update deshalb will
ich dieses das ist ein schneller ändert
das alles geil so sachen die man halt
denkt so war das wäre cool dass das
verbessern aber siehst du innerlich zu
die größten wünsche sind etwas unter
trotzdem an zugefügt dass jetzt weiß
nicht dass man direkt leisten kann dass
man schneller rendern kann
dass die sachen schneller hier geändert
werden dass die sich landschaften
schneller aufbauen und halt dieses
regenbogenstaat auch mega witzig und ja
sonst meine lieben freunde würde ich
sagen ich hoffe es hat euch trotzdem
gefallen auch wenn ich euch den song
nicht zeigen konnte und sonst wenn es
euch gefallen hat die geht einfach mal
einen daumen hoch oder daumen runter
wenn es euch nicht gefallen hat und dann
will ich sagen